[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire vivons-nous vraiment dans
une dictature comme le disent certains
il suffit de comparer notre pays avec de
vraies dictatures pour se persuader
qu'il en est rien et pourtant beaucoup
se sont étonnés de la facilité avec
laquelle les français se sont accommodés
depuis le début de la crise du coc vide
de la disparition de leur liberté comme
siros y était préparé depuis belle
lurette comme si on ne demandait que ça
c'est la thèse du livre de mathieu cela
madiot la liberté qui vient juste de
paraître d'après lui c'est avec
l'assentiment d'une majorité de français
que s'est installée dans notre pays une
société disciplinaire un totalitarisme
soft mais est ce que c'est vrai passées
les mesure exceptionnelle et provisoire
lille est la lutte contre la pandémie
est ce qu'on est vraiment moins libre
qu'avant est ce qu'on est vraiment au
train de succomber aux attraits de la
discipline et de la servitude pour en
débattre nous avons invité mathieu slama
vous êtes analyste politique vous
enseigner la communication politique
hôtel salle de l'école des hautes études
en sciences de l'information et de la
communication et vous venez de publier
la semaine dernière aux presses de la
cité à dieu liberté et c'est sur la
société disciplinaire
on est vraiment dans une dictature vous
pas que la question a opposé à ça c est
ce qu on est en démocratie est-ce qu'on
est encore en démocratie voyez vous et
moi la réponse est non je veux dire très
clairement en tout cas on n'est plus
dans une démocratie tel qu'on l'a connu
il ya encore quelques années si on prend
vraiment en deux phrases mais si on
prend en considération la manière dont
les décisions sont prises en conseil de
défense de manière totalement opaque et
très autoritaire premièrement
deuxièmement la nature des mesures qui
sont prises qui sont des mesures
liberticides est un mot faible vous
allez décrire c'est les mesures les plus
graves qui n'ont jamais été prises en
france depuis une cinquantaine d'années
et si on prend aussi en compte l'absence
de contre-pouvoir la faillite pour moi
je parle de faillite en du conseil
d'état conseil constitionnel et puis
enfin juste pour finir la méthode de
gouvernement qui est inventé et
j'aimerais bien y revenir plus tard mais
une méthode de gouvernement extrêmement
autoritaire et qui
consiste ci a non seulement discriminées
mais insulter ans des millions de
français si on met ça les les uns à côté
des autres moi je considère que nous ne
sommes plus vraiment en démocratie
nicolas bouzou vous êtes économiste vous
diriger un cabinet de conseil et
d'analysé vous êtes éditorialiste à
l'express votre dernier livre ces homos
sanitas histoire et avenir de la santé
qui est paru chez xo en mars 2021 le
prochain doit s'intituler pour un
libéralisme populaire il sortira le 2
mars aux éditions de l'observatoire
trouvez pas qu'on est dans une dictature
vous non je ne trouve pas dans une
dictature non parce que on peut dire ce
qu'on veut la liberté de parole et total
en france on peut vraiment dire ce qu'on
veut où on veut on peut manifester les
mesures très pénible qui ont été prises
depuis deux ans l'ont été fait dans le
cadre de l'étape 3 le parlement a
continué de fonctionner la question en
fait qui m'intéresse c'est
est ce que la france
pourrait perdre sa liberté ses terres
est ce que le risque de dictature
existent répond c'est toujours oui bien
évidemment c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle moi j'ai fait de ma vie
femme je consacre ma vie à la défense de
la de la liberté donc je pense qu'il
existe des menaces sur la liberté je
pense qu'il existe des menaces sur
l'état de droit mais je ne pense pas et
j'imagine que ce sera une différence
entre nous que ce sont les mesures
prises pendant la pause mais la pandémie
qui menace le plus l'état de droit mais
en revanche cette question la question
que vous posez une question qu'ils
doivent faire à mon sens pour les
libéraux dont je fais partie mais
l'objet d'une vigilance et même d'un
combat de tous les instants alors il va
beaucoup plus loin mathieu là bas
puisque vous dites que si nous avons
aussi facilement abandonner nos libertés
c'est cloud étions déjà plus libre moi
je penses tu donc ça date pas du caïdat
non je pense qu'il faut analyser ce que
le cataclysme qui a lieu actuellement
parce que on n'est pas dans l'ordre
d'une menace on est actuellement dans
une situation très grave ça ne s'est pas
passer du jour au lendemain alors
évidemment on un jour tout d'un coup
l'état a décidé que les citoyens
n'avaient plus droit de mettre le pied
dehors et ne pouvait le faire qu'à
certaines heures et avec un système
policier qui s'est mis en place c'est un
état policier qui s'est mis en place
pour s'assurer que les citoyens sortait
à telle heure de la bonne manière grave
natation c'est quand même nous qui nous
donnions l'autorisation de sortir oui
c'est ça sert on s'autorise est soi même
une trouvaille assez folle et je crois
qu'il est quasiment unique grue
commandeur le génie de la bureaucratie
française mais c'est en même temps une
technique de nage c'est à dire inspiré
ddd des sciences comportementales donc
on voit là encore je reviens sur la
dimension disciplinaire de ce qui s'est
passé c'est à dire on va utiliser toutes
les techniques à notre disposition y
compris les plus autoritaires mais aussi
les plus sournoises pour amener les gens
à bien se comporter et à se comporter de
la bonne manière maintenant que vous le
dites et c'est ce que je crois est ce
que je défends c'est que c'est les
français ont voulu ça enfin une majorité
de français et le confinement il une
très très grande majorité françaises
l'ont plébiscité et vous avez même des
parents via une association de jeunes
avocats par exemple qui a demandé au
conseil d'état de demander à l'état
d'être encore plus dur qu'est ce qu'a
fait le conseil d'état alors il a dit
non on va peut-être pas les skoda mais
il a fait des recommandations quand même
à l'état pour dire vous devriez le plus
dur dans la mise en place de confinement
donc comment une telle ou telle les
crises de la liberté a pu se passer
comme ça durant non moi je crois qu'en
effet il faut le voir dans le ton nom
face au terrorisme on a fait le choix de
l'état d'urgence tsi permanent on a fait
aussi le choix par exemple de mettre des
mesures d'exception dans le droit commun
donc on a face aux crises qui équipent
red hat et le co vide on a déjà mis en
place des mesures tout à fait
attentatoires aux libertés et ces
mesures qui ont été elles mêmes
plébiscité par les français donc je
pense que ce qui s'est passé ça n'a été
possible que avec l'assentiment des
français mais aussi parce que finalement
il y avait un terreau favorable à ce
alors moi c'est ce que j'avais en iran
la tête mais c'est ce que j'appelle
l'idéologie du safe l'idée que
finalement notre société aujourd'hui
elle tient sur un paradigme qui n'est
plus celui de la liberté mais quelle
celui de la sécurité la précaution et de
la protection même voilà et que dans
tous les pans de notre vie aujourd'hui
la liberté de dire une chose
inacceptable voire dangereuse est
quelque chose que désormais on considère
qu'il est tout à fait secondaire dans
notre édifice démocratique et puis dans
notre dans notre société et si ça s'est
mis en place si facilement et chenilles
là dessus parce que finalement tout est
presque banal aujourd'hui le
niger a peut-être le pass sanitaire
vaccinale maintenant est une chose
banale les gens ça ne choque plus
personne quasiment ses rentrées presque
dans les habitudes bon si ça ça s'est
installée cette manière aussi facilement
c'est bien qu'il y avait un terrain un
terreau favorable à sa banque moi je dis
la responsabilité du pouvoir les normes
on y reviendra sans doute mais la
responsabilité des français dans le fait
d'avoir plébiscité ces mesures elle est
aussi très important tout le mois
nicolas bouzou alors j'ai plusieurs
choses à dire déjà je ne pense pas que
ces mesures soient plébiscités je pense
au contraire que l'appétit de liberté
n'a jamais été aussi important
qu'aujourd'hui justement parce qu'on en
a était privée moi j'ai sourire je veux
pas parler de moi mais je le prends à
titre d'exemple j'ai soutenu le pass
sanitaire j'ai soutenu le pass vaccinale
mais si jamais une fois que la situation
sera normalisée le pass vaccinale
n'était pas supprimée mais je serai en
tête des cortèges oui merci injustement
jetés
normalité c'est une situation dans
laquelle notre système de santé ne sera
pas menacé à chaque instant aujourd'hui
encore il est complètement engorgé et
l'argument qui consiste à dire il aurait
suffit d'augmenter
les capacités d'accueil à l'hôpital où
les capacités d'accueil en réanimation
savent pas ce que c'est qu'une
exponentielle dire que si vous augmentez
les capacités d'accueil en réanimation
en réalité vous gagnez un tout petit peu
de temps mais vous pouvez jamais être
configuré vous pouvez jamais avoir la
taille de l'épidémie telles que celles
que l'on a connues puisque si c'était ça
on leur effet est bien évident mais ça
n'a pas ça n'a pas été fait et donc je
ne crois pas ça c'est le premier point
que les français soient réticents à
l'idée de liberté tout cas moi à titre
personnel c'est pas mon cas mais ce que
je voudrais vous dire qu'il me semble
encore plus fondamental c'est que
vous avez eu la gentillesse de citer le
livre que j'ai sorti il ya un an sur
l'histoire de la santé en fait il y a
deux types de maux m11x qui
déstabilisent véritablement une société
ayant naguère que deux c'est la guerre
et les épiler les épidémies ont toujours
eu au cours de l'histoire un impact
extrêmement dévastateur sur les sociétés
pourquoi parce qu'un virus c'est quelque
chose qui se propage un peu tout seul et
le virus a des implications liberticide
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que si
vous ne prenez pas de mesure vous avez
quand même une absence de liberté savez
le brésil au moment où molson arrow
avait décidé de tout laisser ouvert bien
des gens que vous et il est assez the
fray qui d'ailleurs restaurant ah non là
il n'allait pas restant n'avait pas en
boîte de nuit il ne faisait pas ce
qu'ils avaient envie de faire donc on
avait la double peine on avait
l'enfermement sans avoir aucun gain en
matière de en matière de santé et donc
les mesures que l'on a prise elle était
extrêmement pénible à titre personnel
moi qui suis un libéral je les ai très
mal vécu de son moi c'est bien simple
tout ce que je vais faire c'est interdit
voilà mais pourquoi est-ce que j'ai
quand même considéré qu'il fallait
l'accepter parce que je savais bien que
si on ne faisait rien on ne serait pas
dans une situation qui aurait été
meilleure et donc les mesures qui ont
été prises je pense que grosso modo
alors on peut en discuter évidemment je
pense que grosso modo elle devait être
prise mais bien évidemment il y à un
combat pour retrouver notre liberté
quand cette phase pour nous michael
passera jamais d'ailleurs sont alors je
m'exprime pas sur les questions
médicales et sanitaires parce que je
suis incompétent et je laisse ça aux
médecins et d'après ce que j'en
comprends on nous explique qu'on entre
dans une période qui est une période
pandémie qui est complètement
indéterminée donc le virus on leur a
peut-être toujours en tout cas c'est ce
que j'en comprends mais à partir du
moment où on sera en tout cas dans une
situation où notre système de santé
pourra absorber ce virus très bien bien
évidemment il faudra lever en tout cas
de mon point de vue et moi je militerai
pour ça je militerai pour la levée du
pinceau actionnaires
actuels moi je crois vous minimisez de
manière assez étonnante l'impact de
toutes ces mesures sur notre modèle
démocratique et la meilleure danse a
profondément ébranlé nous nous à la fois
nous nous réflexes démocratiques mais
même notre autre sens de la liberté est
juste une chose très très étonnant qui
se passe actuellement le gouvernement
est en train de se faire passer pour le
libérateur des français gouvernement
nous dit regardez c'est grâce à nous
vous êtes libre vous avez le pas ce qui
nous permet la liberté et pourquoi parce
que s'il y avait pas tout ça vous serez
enfermé seraient confinés
non non c'est pas de la politique d'une
part c'est gravissime c'est gravissime
qu'un gouvernement dise une chose
pareille mais ensuite dans les esprits
chez des gens
c'est un discours entendable c'est à
dire que oui et d'ailleurs on entend
autour de nous un meilleur grâce à ça on
est libre c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'idée même d'être enfermé chez soi est
une hypothèse tout à fait valable tout à
fait possible et l'idée donc que le pas
ce qui est quand même le passé tu sais
quoi c'est du chantage à la liberté vous
êtes d'accord avec un pas du tout ça
chante à la liberté c'est de vivre c'est
de dire bah vous vous direz pourquoi je
suis pas je vais essayer je vais essayer
de vous convaincre mais c'est en gros de
diable sans gros de dire vous voulez
votre liberté on vous la donne mais à
une condition c'est que vous fassiez
vacciner avec vous rappelle bon donc ça
pareil c'est une mesure absolument
inacceptable et si on est libéral on ne
peut pas accepter ça parce que c'est
alors intéressant ils étaient mes
fonctions si on est libéral on ne peut
pas accepter l'idée de la liberté soit
d'une part l'objet d'un chantage
premièrement et deuxièmement soit
conditionnée à un vaccin aider c'est pas
possible ça on peut pas accepter ça si
on est libéral et je finis sur un point
c'est en gros et c'est là que je pense
notre plus grande différence est que je
pense que vous ne voyez pas le mal que
ça fait à notre pays est ce que
j'entendais récemment une députée l'air
om dont j'ai oublié le nom qui a dit une
chose qui marque qui m'a glacé le sang
elle a dit le patron
on s'en sépara bientôt ce qui est
possible en d'ailleurs moi je crois tout
à fait conscient c'est par à bientôt
mais ça fait partie de la boîte à outils
c'est dans la boîte à outils même et
vous voyez c'est ça que vous me voyez
pas c'est que désormais dans notre
horizon des possibles démocratique le
confinement le couvre-feu même le masque
en extérieur qui pour moi est une mesure
absolument aberrante et
anticonstitutionnelle regarde de tous
nos principes fondamentaux sur l'autre
sur le pointer et en plus sur le plan
scientifique visiblement ces voix là et
ils le passent cette idée de passe qui
est encore une fois pour moi c'est
presque un permis de citoyenneté 1 vous
êtes citoyen avec tous vos droits vous
devez avoir votre pass voilà et bien
maintenant ça c'est devenu quelque chose
de possible et quand nous aurons à faire
face à d'autres crises parce que nous
aurons à faire face à d'autres crises
peut-être d'autres épidémies
crise sécuritaire climatique ou quoi que
ce soit c'est des choses qui seront dans
la boîte à outils et ça vous ne voyez
pas et je je je ne sais pas pourquoi
peut-être que vous allez pouvoir nous
l'expliquer mais que vous soyez aveugle
sur une telle gravité est sûre et sur la
normalisation de choses aussi graves
séquelles show six mois m'interpelle et
ça m'interpelle d'autant plus que la
plupart des libéraux défendu ces mesures
là et ça c'est quand même étonnant qu'au
nom de la plupart en tout cas j'ai vu
assez peu de libéraux
se battre au nom de la liberté contre
ces mesures je sers vue assez peu
d'intellectuels se battre ces vraies
mesures qu'elle fige pas de quelques
bords que ça me barbara siegler et et à
gand ben en italie c'est vrai qu'ils
sont ils sont très rares et c'est vrai
que ça doit nous interroger et finit là
dessus que j'ai sur finalement l'état de
notre démocratie
l'état aussi de encore une fois on
revient au sujet initial mais l'état de
notre goût pour la liberté qui est en
train de s'effacer
bon c'est bien on est dans interdit
d'interdire on a un peu de temps
vous aimez rémois oui alors je ne sais
pas mama bâ tradition philosophique
c'est du bonbon moi c'est même très bas
grosso modo c'est la tradition
philosophique
le dernier la dernière conférence au
collège de france de raymond aron
portait justement sur la notion de
liberté et raymond aron explique je
trouve de façon absolument lumineuse que
il ya un sophisme chez les libéraux qui
est que la liberté ce serait un tout au
fond qu'il n'y aurait que deux régimes
possibles un régime de vie total est un
régime d'absence de liberté zurich c'est
quelque chose qui est très en vogue chez
les ch et les libéraux y compris
d'ailleurs je sais des libéraux comme
mario vargas llosa par exemple qui sont
des gens vraiment voilà pour moi qui
sont aussi sources d'une très grande
inspiration et raymond avant explique je
crois de façon très juste que ça c'est
conceptuel mais dans la vraie vie ça se
passe pas comme ça il y a des libertés
il y a des libertés et la grande
difficulté politique concrète c'est que
pour que certaines de ces libertés
puisse vivre pour que l'on puisse en
jouir il faut malheureusement en réduire
d'autres si ça n'était pas comme ça mais
que la vie serait simple il n'y aurait
pas de débat intellectuel tout le monde
voudrait faire de la politique et tout
le monde réussir est à faire de la
politique malheureusement la vie n'est
pas comme ça et raymond aron évidemment
prend pas l'exemple d'une crise
sanitaire mais il prend l'exemple de la
protection des biens et il explique bien
que si on veut jouir de notre propriété
la pratique le droit de propriété est en
délire aussi l'une des bases delà de la
théorie libérale depuis longtemps eh
bien on est obligés d'interdire un
certain nombre de choses et on est
obligé d'avoir une force armée une
justice on est obligé d'avoir une
coercition tout ceci est extrêmement
pénible mais on n'a pas le on a pas le
choix il se trouve que pendant une
période pandémique parce que vous me
dites que je sous-estiment telle chose
telle chose de très longs évidemment je
suis tout à fait prêt à l'entendre c'est
tout à fait prêt entendez des critiques
entend beaucoup d'air mais moi aussi je
peux vous avoir à ce petit jeu là vous
sous-estimé
l'impact d'une pandémie des pandémies
comme celle que l'on a connue c'est
extrêmement rare alors peut-être pas la
pandémie d'aujourd'hui avec des
variantes qui semble un petit peu moins
délétère que le virus du début mais je
peux vous dire que au début un virus qui
envoient entre 10 et 15 % des gens qui
sont touchés à l'hôpital c'est grosso
modo l'équivalent du choléra si vous
restez à peu près et qui se diffuse de
façon très rapide c'est quelque chose
qui est terrible pour une société si
vous faites rien vous êtes sur le bellec
société j'ai toujours dit et il a été
dit sur ce plateau c'est un virus qui
est très contagieux wiki tu peux je
parle des complications oui je parle pas
ça oui mais une épidémie sais pas j'ai
aussi beaucoup entendu ça on va beaucoup
dit mais c'est un virus qui tu peux pas
le sujet pas le sujet parce qu'on vit
russie les militaires tuent beaucoup oui
voilà mais quand vous avez des gens qui
étouffe ce qui s'est passé au brésil
quand vous avez des gens qui étouffe
dans la rue
donc c'est pas simplement là c'est pas
simplement le nombre de décès ce pas
simplement le taux de létalité qui
compte mais quand vous avez ça vous êtes
obligé de prendre des mesures pour
préserver la liberté et j'ai considéré
que le pass sanitaires et le pass
vaccinale était les restrictions de
liberté bien évidemment vous avez raison
mais qui permettait qui étaient celles
qui étaient les mieux calibrée pour que
nous puissions continuer à vivre donc le
pas à peu près le passé la liberté
absolument absolument c'est l'outil qui
donne la liberté est-ce que c'est pas
possible et ce que
je vais proposer de parce que pour bien
comprendre votre point matthieussent
tabac si je mets un masque à l'intérieur
si je me fais vacciner et si j'utilise
mon pass vaccinale pour aller ici ou là
est ce que ça fait de moi
un
citoyen policiers et dans ce cas là est
ce que le tram piste de base qui refuse
absolument tout ce que tout ce que je
viens d'énumérer ce que ça fait l'ua
résistants non je pense qu'il faut pas
en effet si on est dans cette nombre
dans cette caricature mais je sais je
vois très mal en valeur sa démarche
comme tous les deux mois c'est pas du
tout ce que je dis moi je dis d'une part
déjà je pense que on oublie une chose
dans cette crise et est encore une fois
je pense que la tradition libérale
aurait pu tout à fait rejoindre mon
point de vue ça c'est que les les
français ne sont pas des enfants et ça
c'est une chose qu'on a un peu oublié ce
avec tocqueville donc vous connaissez
simple il faisait le grand danger pour
les pour les démocraties occidentales
c'est pas l'un tyrans et dictateurs
c'est un tuteur un tuteur quelqu'un qui
se finalement sécu près du bonheur des
gens et tout irait bien et voilà eh ben
c'est un peu ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
c'est là ou telle ville avait peut-être
été le plus visionnaire de tous c'est
que aujourd'hui nous sommes des enfants
et l'état s'occupe de réguler de liberté
et sa fougue s'ils avaient très bien
j'ai d'ailleurs mais ils l'assument
d'ailleurs dans son discours il le
désigne comme à des enfants super
totalement on ya les responsables il ya
les irresponsables il ya les bons
citoyens il ya les mauvais citoyen il ya
ceux qui font emmerder parce que
visiblement ils n'ont pas le bon
comportement
et que sais-je encore on dit aux
français alors ça moi c'est un peu moins
important il ya beaucoup de gens qui
insistent là-dessus pour moi mais on dit
aux français comment faire la fête comme
la france est devenue une cour d'école à
discipliner et voilà donc les français
sont responsables ce sont pas des
enfants et je pense qu'il n'est pas
besoin de confinement policiers parce
que c'est ça un final confinement
policiers pour que les français restent
chez eux fassent attention voilà les
français sont des gens responsables mais
je voudrais vous dire justement sur la
base de sa vous répondre parce que à
vous écouter en fait on a l'impression
que les petites petites suppression de
liberté c'est pas grave et j'ai lu votre
ouvrage d'ailleurs ou à la fin vous
parler de tout ça et il manque
et ils pensent que tout est là il manque
dans votre analyse des mots absolument
essentiel il manque le mot république il
manque le mot citoyenneté il manque le
mot révolution française il manque le
mot ou parler de bruce sanitas alors il
manque le mot état de droit voilà ils
manquent tous ces mots là et vous
analysez la crise politiquement et vous
ne voyez pas le coeur du problème le
coeur du problème c'est quoi c'est qu'en
fait on n'a pas vécu des petites
suppression de liberté moi je pense
qu'on a vécu un moment
contre-révolutionnaire c'est à dire que
tous les acquis de la révolution
française des actifs républicains se
sont envolés dès qu'elle le peut être le
truc le plus évident qu'on peut évoquer
c'est la citoyenneté le pas ce que vous
défendez c'est une rupture sans
précédent dans notre conception de la
cité broyarde je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi parce que dans la république
française il n'ya pas nationalité et
indivisible n'y a pas d'aidé ça n'existe
pas il ya pas les citoyens de première
au citoyen de seconde zone savez bien
que les femmes n'ont pas voté alors 1944
dans dans l'esprit voilà dans le sauna
et dont il sait très secrète sans vous
fassiez référence à ça parce que
justement toute l'histoire des luttes
sociales et des acquis c'est justement
pour lutter contre ça et ebit est pour
l'égalité donc on fait une rupture
fondamentale qui avait déjà été tenté il
ya quelques années avec la déchéance de
nationalité qui avait été proposé par
françois hollande et qui avait été
retoqué et notamment le défenseur des
droits à l'époque avait dit on touche à
lundi vise à bil'in divisibilité de la
state bank ça st ensuite on touche à
la méthode de gouvernement on passe à
une méthode de gouvernement extrêmement
autoritaire extrêmement punitive
répressive disciplinaire policiers etc
qui là aussi est totalement
contradictoire avec la logique
républicaine qui selon moi elle est
profondément libérale et c'est pour ça
que là dessus vous devriez être d'accord
avec moi c'est que la république c'est
quoi c'est un état qui protège les
droits des citoyens voyez est ce assez
libérale oui et ça c'est dans la
tradition libérale normalement ça a
toujours été ça et je file juste sur un
point la troisième rupture finalement si
voilà c est vous l'avez évoqué c'est le
citoyen policiers alors que j'évoque un
petit peu ça dans mon livre de votre
expression c'est un peu et c'est mon
expression
elle vaut ce qu'elle vaut mais en tout
cas ce que je pense c'est qu'on a créé
un peu cette nouvelle figure alors d'une
part dans le fait que les français n'ont
pu se sont mis à pied à ses pieds les
uns les autres je raconte notamment une
anecdote à la mairie du 18e
arrondissement à paris les lignes de
police ont été saturés et la mairie a dû
faire un message aux administrés pour
l'heure arrêté d'appeler la police pour
faire de la délation sur les les
contrevenants au confinement donc c'est
mis en place un peu cette société
disciplinaire mais foucault voyez la
société cible des nerfs de l'état ou aux
citoyens mais c'est les citoyens eux
mêmes qui ont créé les conditions de sa
société la fille deuxièmement avec le
pass
vous créer une rupture aussi important
dans le fait que c'est des citoyens qui
joue un rôle de police en vérifiant des
qr codes déjà l'idée même de qr code
pour accéder à des lieux et volent
n'importe quel libéral devra être choqué
par ça mais ensuite vous faites
contrôler les citoyens les uns les
autres avec aussi des policiers ensuite
qui sont chargés de contrôler les
contrôleurs et puis éventuellement
peut-être les policiers eux mêmes un
jour seront contrôlés bon donc cette
société là personne n'en veut une
pandémie ne justifie pas été comme ça il
ya des pays qui ont mis en place des
mesures beaucoup moins restrictive plus
intelligente qui font appel à la
responsabilité individuelle de chacun et
ça n'a peut-être pas été un miracle du
point de vue de la santé publique mais
c'est pas non plus été un cataclysme
donc ce que je dis simplement c'est que
on la touche on n'a pas raconté à des
petites libertés on a tout détruit dans
cette histoire il faut dire que je
préfère je vous donne la parole que
c'est vrai qu'on sait peu comment ça se
passe à l'étranger j'ai essayé de le
faire dans cette émission mais c'est
toujours compliqué on croit que tout le
monde a fait comme nous ça n'est pas
vrai c'est pas ça n'est pas vrai enfin
si nicolas bouzou alors ça n'est pas
vrai si je puis témoigner il se trouve
qu'après l'instauration du pass
sanitaire pas du post vaccinale mais du
passé et r j'ai beaucoup voyagé dans des
pays parfaitement démocratique je suis
allé en suisse je suis allé en allemagne
et en europe tous ces pays et en europe
voilà et dans tous ces pays ça m'était
jamais arrivé d'ailleurs notamment en
suisse c'est la première fois qu'en
suisse on me dit on va imiter la france
parce que vous menez une bonne politique
publique la suisse n'étant pas un pays
fasciste ainsi d'un pays aussi il ya
très libéral
entend bien mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que si on veut pousser l'analyse
jusqu'au bout et ont donné quand même
que dans les pays dans les démocraties
libérales disons beaucoup de pays ont
mis en place des politiques qui a des
détails près mais ressembler à la
politique de la france et le pass
sanitaire a été un dispositif qui a été
imité pour le coup par beaucoup d'autres
pays bas il faut aussi assumer le fait
si on est dans cette analyse là bas il
faut considérer que c'est tout
l'occident qui est en train de tomber
dans une partie de l'europe qui est en
train de tomber dans une quasi dictature
très honnêtement ça défie un peu le bon
sens ça vous pouvez m'expliquer que la
suisse l'allemagne l'italie basse et une
tonne de lait v6 est la première à la
première question de jeu frédéric taddeï
non mais bon ben on veut jouer sur les
mots mais frédéric taddeï l'a prononcée
vous avez pas les pendules à l'heure
dans ghoulam les partait pas
soyez les régimes autoritaires des
régimes totalitaires bon alors régime
autoritaire dont il ya aussi un régime
autoritaire en allemagne est aussi en
suisse mais aussi en italie on a eu
aussi engaly surtout donc ouais ouais
non d'accord drian ce qui se passe en
voilà oui ben vous voyez mais en fait
non c'est pas être un
argument si le bon sens ça compte si si
franchement si je vous prends avec
réponse profil vous promets que quand on
va se promener dans ces pays mais quand
on va se promener on pourra prendre
l'exemple des exemples dans tes limites
dans des pays dans lesquels vraiment on
peut pas dire ce qu'on veut y compris
dans les médias si je peux vous dire que
c'est quelque chose qui compte on fait
une pause on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
l'actualité économique de la semaine
décryptées par olivier delamarche le rsa
remplit t-il ses objectifs non à en
croire un rapport de la cour des comptes
comment voulez-vous avec un peu plus de
500 euros vous en tirez et vous loger et
c'est donc évidemment que c'est pas un
tremplin pour quoi que ce soit je pense
que le dispositif aura une efficacité si
on est dans une économie réellement
solidaire pour à l'édition 2022 choose
france 21 projets d'investissements ont
été annoncées en france il ya une
contrepartie qu'on va promettre à des
entreprises si elles viennent
s'implanter que d'abord on les embêtera
pas trop sur les licenciements qu'ils
annonceront après et vous aurez une une
déduction fiscale ou des aides pour vous
installer pendant une période donnée
méfiez-vous qu'on l'appelle pas bientôt
luz france aussi
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et vit la
population africaine c'est un milliard
d'habitants c'est ça à la valeur de nos
crypto monnaie
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement qu'en
dit que l'argent liquide perd de la
valeur beaucoup de pays en afrique ont
interdit la crypto est ce que vous
répondez à cela une canette on ne peut
pas dire on va interdire la crypto
d'autant qu'il ya internet il y aura des
crypto
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat avec mathieu
slama qui publie un dieu la liberté
à la cité voilà je cherchais le nom de
l'éditeur et d'ical aboudou l'auteur de
hobo sanitas quel éditeur au botanique
xo xo et qui publiera le 2 mars aux
éditions de l'observatoire pour un
libéralisme populaire
alors dans toute cette affaire et là on
parle plus particulièrement depuis le
début de la crise du code vide ce que
nous avait vécu
cette société de contrôle dont que vous
dénoncez dans votre livre est ce que
c'est le maquereau nisme ou est ce que
c'est la bureaucratie
c'est une bonne question parce que on
peut aussi considérer que finalement
donné la bureaucratie c max weber hills
et la bureaucratie de vie dans son
propre sa propre norme et devient un peu
incontrôlable et peut finalement
reprendre le contrôle sur moi je fais
pas cette analyse là je le pense au
contraire que tout ça découle de
décision politique même si c'est très
très influencé par la science mais moi
je fais un peu l'hypothèse que
et ça rejoint un peu nous débat sur
libéralisme je pense que dans le
maquereau nisme il y a une
prédisposition à l'autoritarisme et à
prendre ce type de mesures est la raison
de cela c'est que au fond moi je crois
qu'on a vécu un grand moment managériale
c'est à dire que du jour au lendemain
les citoyens français se sont
transformés en population alors que
savaient les médecins disent population
générale les français se sont
transformés dans cette histoire en
population générale à gérer à manager et
du coup de pouvoir s'est fait un peu
manager du dd de la population française
alors avec des graphiques des courbes
des à l'aide des scientifiques etc on a
managé les français on les a enfermés on
les a des consignes et on a confiné on a
mis en place des couvre feux ensuite on
et met en place des outils ne dépasse
enfin on a fait une sorte de grande de
grands comment dire de grandes
opérations de management et ça je crois
que le les maquereaux nist sont issus du
monde du management et je pense que
c'est pas un hasard si les maquereaux
nice et je finis juste sur ça parce que
ça me paraît vraiment important qui
finalement sont des gens qui n'ont moi
j'ai beaucoup débattu avec eux sur des
plateaux sur ces sujets là c'est pas des
gens qui pensent à mal en fait tu ne
vois même pas où est le problème et
c'est des gens qui n'ont aucune culture
républicaine sont pas de culture
démocratique
ils savent pas ce que c'est les
sans-culottes les soldats de l'an ii ils
savent pas ce que c'est ils n'ont jamais
lu un discours de jaurès de blum ou même
de clemenceau de leur vie donc ces deux
ans ils n'ont pas conscience en fait de
ce qu'ils font et ils font avec la
france qui ferait avec une entreprise
c'est-à-dire qui managent il manage
alors ce qui est efficace si on fermait
des gens c'est efficace mais on le fait
si m dépasser efficacement on fait aussi
et du coup ils n'ont pas le surmoi
démocratique républicain qui fait que
peut-être non un gouvernement un peu
plus au fait de ces choses-là aura été
beaucoup plus prudent donc moi je
n'accable pas le maquereau nice mais j'y
vois quand même une part de
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe et
ça nous ça nous renvoie aussi à la
responsabilité des libéraux je pense que
c'est peut-être ça le le lien aussi
c'est aujourd'hui les libéraux défendent
la liberté économique défendre le
management de défendre défendre dungey
toutes ces mesures qui sont profondément
anti libérale en réalité avant de donner
la parole à nicolas blues juste pour
préciser votre votre point de vue moi il
me semble que j'ai pu comprendre de la
politique du gouvernement depuis le
début de la crise due qu'aux vols au
départ ça a été de tous nous enfermer
enfin tous nous confiner plus exactement
et puis pas tant ces de tous nous
vacciner et en fait ils sont passés
progressivement de l'un à l'autre des
qui a vu des vaccins il s'agit de tout
le monde vacciner et avant cela mais
c'était tout ce nous confiner puis à
près de nous des confiné un tout petit
peu mais avec toujours la menace de nous
re confiné en fait si l'on fait tout ça
mais c'est pas par méchanceté ses 9 ans
par incompétence par ignorance par peur
particularisme aussi par une élite
harris mme parent oui bon élève qu'il
pouvait ce à quoi ils sont morts
puisqu'il voyait faire par les voisins
jeu absolument je pense que le la chine
mais surtout l'italie parce que 10 c'est
l'italie juste après la chine est le
pays qui a mis en place les évoquerons
plus douloureux pour eux parce qu'ils
pensaient que ça ne pouvait pas nous
arriver oui ils ont regardé et la
fidélité en se disant jamais ça
n'arrivera chez nous tout à fait il ya
un autre point aussi est vraiment un mot
mais le rôle des scientifiques parce que
dans cette histoire les scientifiques
ont joué comme un rôle énorme en ont les
a beaucoup vu sur les plateaux de
télévision voilà limiteront tant mieux
parce que leur avis importe mais les
scientifiques se sont transformés en
politique voilà alors tout d'un coup on
a vu des scientifiques nous disent qu'il
fallait confiné qu'il fallait mettre des
couvre-feux qu'il fallait mettre des
masques aux gens de l'extérieur en tout
cas et qu'il fallait mettre des passes
mais moi je redis c'est quelque chose
que je dis beaucoup c'est que les
scientifiques ne sont pas légitimes pour
moi à défendre des mesures qui sont des
mesures politiques qui répondent à des
critères démocratiques et tic
socio-économique monstrueux ça dépasse
de très loin la question scientifique et
je crois que les scientifiques qui avec
notamment le conseil scientifique mais
pas seulement et c'est on joue un rôle
immense dans cette histoire parce que
ils ont en quelque en quelque sorte
légitimé les mesures les plus
autoritaires au nom de la science qui se
discute pas et c'est là où si le
grain problème démocratique qu'on a
connu c'est que il n'y a pas eu de
filtres démocratique entre le
fonds va dire les points de vue
scientifique voilà et le chiffre
normalement qui doit s'opérer qui le
filtre politique qui répond à plein
d'autres enjeux que et ce jeu dangereux
sanitaire voilà donc je pense que c'est
une responsabilité collective en voilà
et les français voilà mais la science
sociale joue un rôle dans cette histoire
alors nicolas bouzou management ou
manipulation parce que d'autres vont
plus loin et 10 parle de manipulation
alors ce que ne dit pas non c'est utile
à la population si on pense notamment
aux passes vaccinale pour moi le kazakh
sinal comme le passé à lithaire c'est un
outil de santé publique c'est à dire que
au fond il ya un objectif qui est de
faire en sorte que la part la plus
importante de la population soit
vaccinée ça on peut en discuter moi
c'est un objectif auquel j'adhère mais
cas c'est l'objectif est ensuite vous
avez deux moyens possibles pour arriver
à ça soit vous faites une vaccination
obligatoire mais je crois que de façon
assez concrète c'est difficile à faire
soit vous faites un outil qui est pas
alors c'est pas d'une audience c'est
beaucoup plus que ça c'est une quasi
obligation en réalité donc moi
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on peut pas
refait le gouvernement aurait pu
parfaitement le dire clairement et on a
considéré quand je dis on c'est abstrait
il a été considéré que c'était la façon
la plus efficace de faire et donc je
crois qu'ils voient là et je suis
d'ailleurs plutôt plutôt d'accord les
gouvernements l'actionnaire bakr on dit
qu'il est emmerdé les dons parce que
j'aime pas ça oui nombre ont failli le
dollar n'a là et non mais oui absolument
ah oui absolument on peut être pour ces
mesures mais contre cette façon de
s'exprimer moi je ne pense pas qu'un
teaser lie le dire clairement
écoutez d'accord mais alors le champ
c'est moi qui suis sur ce plateau et on
parle de ça et moi je n'aime pas cette
façon de parler de parler aux français
sur la question en algérie'' alors me
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous mais
j'ai même beaucoup plus loin de vous je
pense que le management dans les
entreprises et le management des
entreprises appliqué au secteur public
est une catastrophe pardonnez-moi de
motos site et j'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle la comédie humaine qui avait
fait son petit effet et qui portait là
dessus pardonnez moi pour cette absence
de modestie mais pas celle là donc ton
alors là je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ça sur cette façon de gouverner je
crois qu'une différence entre nous
c'est que
vous êtes
lorsque l'on appelle les types de
conviction c'est à dire que vous voulez
aller vers un modèle idéal et c'est tout
à fait estimable je suis dans l'éthique
de responsabilité
c'est à dire que je me demande en
permanence qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce
que qu'est ce que je ferais si j'étais à
la place de et je pense que ce sont deux
façons de penser qu'ils sont bien la
peine qui est meilleur que l'autre je
pense que les deux sont absolument
légitime et
les deux doivent pouvoir s'exprimer mais
frédéric taddeï je trouvais un peu
sévère quand même quand vous parliez
d'incompétence de peur de remettre sa
reine le compte de d'accord pardonnez
moi je pensais que ce n'est pas dans ce
délai le préfet ce n'est pas une motion
non meilleurs qu'on n'est pas omniscient
c'était qu'on ne sait pas toujours si
nous explique peut être mais je vous
explique lalanne ma façon de réfléchir
parce que ça peut aussi éclairer notre
notre débat je me demande en permanence
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait et ensuite
je me dis est ce que j'aurai mais fait
mieux ou est ce que j'aurais fait moins
bien un mois très honnêtement alors là
je m'expose vraiment à beaucoup de
critiques de la part de vos
téléspectateurs mais je pense que sa
crise elle n'a pas été si mal géré que
ça y compris en occident d'ailleurs un
fait on disait que l'occident était
matérialiste on disait qu'il était
individualiste on a fait preuve d'une
très grande solidarité en occident on a
au début de la crise arrêtez l'économie
pour soutenir les plus fragiles et c'est
très bien mais c'est pas matérialiste je
pense qu'on a été relativement efficace
les vaccins qui marche le mieux ils sont
pas parfaits mais enfin et c'est quand
même l'occident qui les a qui les a
faits je pense que du point de vue
économique on a été plutôt bon notamment
en france
l'économie a déjà retrouvé son niveau
d'avant crise il ya quasiment pas
d'autres pays dans lequel ça c'est ça
c'est produit donc je trouve que tout ça
quand même a été plutôt bien mené mais
je le dis parce que je suis dans
l'éthique de responsabilité
après vous dites on a des libertés en
moins c'est terrible mais je vais vous
dire vous avez raison pour ça que j'ai
bien aimé votre livre d'ailleurs me suis
pas d'accord sur le fond mais oui on a
des libertés en moins mais là où je
diffère complètement de vous c'est que
je pense que ces libertés
fondamentalement elle est liée à cette
catastrophe qui nous est tombé dessus et
qui est ce virus et je pense que la
politique c'est alors dans ces cas là la
platine
je pense que l'heure si vous vous dites
en gros si et le politique
c'est la politique c'est pas noir blanc
je pense que la politique c'est surtout
dans ce type de période c'est le choix
entre des solutions qui sont toutes
mauvaises
mais là on n'y avait pas là il entre
dans ce qu'on avait choisi les moins
mauvaises d'ailleurs dans les pays dans
lesquels il ya plus de restrictions
penser que tout s'est bien passé
personne ne dise pas nadal ça mais je
vais
oui enfin après faudrait que vous nous
expliquer ce que vous auriez fait qu est
ce que vous auriez un exemple non mais
non mais c'est intéressant pour la
vaccination par exemple vous auriez dit
aux gens on va simplement faire de la
pédagogie vous auriez fait une
vaccination obligatoire qu'est ce que
vous auriez fait je vous réponds moi et
après je vais bien sûr je vous écoute
avec beaucoup d'intérêt mais laissez les
gens se vacciner sans mesures de
politiques publiques non parce qu'on
serait pas parce que ce ne serait pas
allé assez vite donc j'étais contre ça
l'obligation a chuté contre parce que je
pense que c'est pas le plus efficace je
pense que c'est difficile mais je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui pour certaines
raisons veulent pas vaccinés et ben qui
se vaccinent pas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'étais favorables aux pass
sanitaire et aux passes vaccinale aller
quand on réfléchit comme ça non pas en
regardant année alors bien sûr et des
gens qui vont vous dire oui mais en fait
vous trompez pas ce que l'épidémie
n'était pas grave on aurait pu vivre
comme ça ok je suis pas d'accord ça et
je laisse ça de côté mais quand vous
essayez d'avoir des objectifs de
politique publique là quand vous prenez
des décisions quand vous devez choisir
n'a aucune n'est parfaite et c'est ça
qui est trafic dans la politique c'est
pour ça que c'est dur c'est pour ça
plein de gens veulent pas faire de
politique et c'est pour ça que ceux qui
font de la politique bien souvent sont
assez impopulaire match est stable à on
peut voir le pass vaccinale autrement
que la façon dont les gens le voient on
peut le voir comme une mesure destinée
non pas à protéger des vaccinés mais à
protéger les noms 25 ans c'est très bien
enfin je crois que tout le monde a fini
par comprendre que en dépit des vaccins
et même des trois doses on peut attraper
le virus est un peu le 2d donc au fond
en empêchant les non-vaccinés de venir
là où vont les vaccinés on les protège
un peu con tre m'a harcelé nouvelle le
rhétorique oui oui c'était le seul nom
il faut faire plus le gouvernement est
en train de se rendre compte que les
arguments d'avant de marché par oui il y
lançant à sa boîte à dons que vous êtes
vous êtes tout à fait en phase
l'argumentaire du moment voilà mais
alors déjà à partir du moment où on
tient ce discours pour moi tout
s'écroule parce que si on protège les
non vaccinés contre eux même les non
vaccinés ils font un choix pour eux
mêmes alors si on est libéral je décide
et décide ce qui est bon pour eux et cdc
des adultes ne sont pas des enfants et
l'état n'a pas à leur dire ce qu'il doit
faire ou pas donc déjà cet argumentaire
pour moi c'est tout ont fait tomber le
château carton nantis pas tout à fait
parce que le manuscrit mais le but c'est
qu'ils n'aillent pas le végétal prendre
la place de quelqu'un qui a eu un
accident
parce que finalement en gros c'est ça la
vivent à la fin en fait on se rend
compte de quoi c'est que le seul
argument qui justifie tout cela c'est le
l'hôpital et la situation c'est la
bourse ou la vie des thèmes bien
peut-être avant de venir là dessus vous
m'avez appris quelque chose du coup là
dans votre dans votre discours m'avait
appris qu'une politique de santé
publique
consisté à à punir de quasi mort sociale
des millions de français voilà ça je ne
savais pas donc vous me l'apprenez parce
que du coup on fait ce que le discours
là c'est enfin notre débat est très bien
mais on en oublie en fait les
conséquences de la politique de l'année
vous gêne ni revenir mais on en oublie
les conséquences de la politique qui est
menée qui consiste quand même
littéralement a condamné interdire en
tout cas de vie sociale des millions
français premièrement potentiellement
les radicaliser encore plus parce que
moi excusez moi si je suis un anti
vaccins et ou en tout cas inquiet par
rapport aux vaccinations c'est pas le
discours du gouvernement s'est passé
insultes et ce n'est pas cette politique
extrêmement autoritaire qui va me
convaincre vous voyez vous je pense que
c'est peut-être même un peu non mais ne
riez vous comme ça
contradictoire à l'horizon la république
même la politique autoritaire qui est
menée si vous voulez je pense qu'elle
est totalement contreproductive et
ensuite non un gouvernement n'a pas le
droit de faire ça un gouvernement on n'a
pas le droit de condamner à la mort
sociale des millions français elle n'a
pas droit au gouvernement d'avoir droit
de dire un tel n'est pas un citoyen un
gouvernement n'a pas le droit de dire
vous êtes responsable êtes pas de
responsable et d'ailleurs ça me fait
penser à une chose c'est que on est en
train dans cette histoire de confondre
roi et morale voilà ce qu'en fait au
fond on a un discours moral trop si
c'est à dire c'était mauvais citoyen ils
sont pas responsables voilà et du couffo
définir mais le droit encore une fois
c'est pas ça il ya la morale le droit la
vaccination vous l'avez dit n'est pas
obligatoire moi je ne fait surtout pas
casser obligatoire mais elle n'est pas
obligatoire donc en plus c'est des gens
qui n'ont même pas enfreint la loi oui
donc c'est encore plus grave parce qu'on
est en train de faire c'est-à-dire qu'on
on est en train de confondre droit et
morale et d'instituer une sorte de
2,2 comment dire ans de permis encore
une fois ce que j'ai déjà appelé d'un
permis de citoyenneté sans lequel on est
plus pleinement citoyens alors qu'on a
enfreint aucune loi je veux dire les non
vaccinés ils payent leurs impôts ils
sont citoyens autant que vous et le mar
donc ça vous voyez je pense qu'une
politique de santé publique qui
justement est juste une politique de
santé publique qui implique ça je vous
comprends pas comment c'est possible fin
voyez vous les gars varier la santé je
vois pas où est la santé publique l'atb
a ensuite abattu vous fait pas d'effort
de bouc est un garçon intelligent en
tout cas match de gala vous concentrez
vous dit vous dit qu'est ce que vous
feriez ou continuer déjà moi j'ai envie
de vous dire vu la situation
catastrophique dans lequel on est je
crois que c'est important déjà de dire
que les choses ne vont pas et d'avoir
des gens qui comme m en tout cas amène
un peu le débat sur la gravité de ce
qu'est en train de se passer ensuite moi
je dis une fois stressant est ce que
tous les pays au monde ont mis en place
des passes et des vaccinations
obligatoires tous non bien sûr que non
non donc ça veut dire que il ya des
alternatives mais savez vous savez la
phrase des néolibéraux il n'y a pas
d'alternative c'est un peu ça là
aujourd'hui c'est à dire il n'y a pas
d'alternative il ya qu un choix on ne
sait pas ce qu'il ya des pays qui n'ont
pas fait de suède la nana pas de passes
pour la vie quotidienne l'angleterre
sort de tout ça il ya des pays qui
arrive à gérer ça de manière
100 des restrictions totalement
démentiel
action et j'ajoute une chose c'est que
réalité on se rend compte de quoi si on
rentre un peu dans le détail c'est que
il ya une étude l'a récemment qui a
montré que 30 à 40% des non vaccinées
étaient des gens qui n'étaient pas
qu'ils n'étaient pas contre la
vaccination ou
anti vaccins que ça c'était des gens qui
étaient dans des déserts médicaux donc
c'était des gens en situation de
précarité sociale ou de d'éloignement
géographique
loin des grandes îles et donc du coup
qu'il n'avait pas l'accès facile à là
mais les nations et du coup c'est pour
ça qu'ils ne se faisait pas à vacciner
donc vous voyez bien que cuba là bas
dont le port est un coup c'est
pourquoi pourquoi punir ces gens là
pourquoi 40% de dénoncer pourquoi punir
ces gens là pourquoi les punir la maison
voyez bien que vous voyez bien que dans
les solutions apportées et bien que
c'est pas la punition qu'il faut laisser
le soir des faits quoi passer à les voir
ces gens
là veut dire mettre des moyens pour
justement le leur permettre de se faire
vacciner ça veut dire peut-être faire
des campagnes aussi qu'il soit peut-être
un peu moins infantilisante puisqu'on a
vu parce que pardon mais des campagnes
sur la vaccination c'est aberrant enfin
je veux dire c'est d'une infantilisation
absolument totale se balader le dp et
s'ajoutera une chose c'est que il faut
aussi comprendre l'inquiétude de
certains sur le vaccin et des gens qui
sont inquiets le rapport au vaccin qui
voit des informations voilà ont ils se
rendent compte que le vaccin n'est pas
efficace compromettre pacifique à ce que
c'est en tout cas contre la transmission
etc ils ont besoin de réponses pourquoi
on les rassure pas c'est pourquoi on
pourquoi il n'ya pas aussi un travail
qui est fait pour 10 rebonds de le
vaccin est pas incroyable mais il y des
idées bien pâle pour telle ou telle ou
telle raison et je pense aussi aux
parents par avoir leurs enfants qui sont
inquiets pour leurs enfants on comprend
tout ça on est des êtres humains on l'a
un peu d'empathie voyez donc la solution
de la punition pardon dans cette
histoire elle est totalement
contreproductive et allait inhumaine
elle est contreproductive et puis elle
est
inutile parce qu'en au fond il ya
d'autres alternatives qu'on peut qu'on
peut mettre en place donc encore une
fois le discours de n'y a pas
d'alternative je le trouve totalement
binaire et il y a il y a toujours des
alternatives et je pense qu'on peut
choisir une vraie politique de santé
publique qui ne soit pas coercitif
punitive comme vous le vous semblez le
des joutes et une question il faut que
je répondrais nicolas bouzou
et ça rebondit sur ce que je disais tout
à l'heure pour dire que le gouvernement
ait pas forcément cynique calculateur et
qui peut et qui n'est pas en mission et
qui peut donc que céder à tout ce qui
est humain à savoir l'ignorance
l'incompétence la peur l'acaic était et
on a vu beaucoup d'autres gouvernements
enfin ça tombe demande de gouvernements
dire des choses qui n'avaient aucun sens
et est malheureusement beaucoup s'en
souviennent je passe sur l'histoire
d'emad ray on il en fallait pas quand on
en avait pas depuis qu'on en a il en
faut tout le temps y compris à
l'extérieur au sérail mais aussi sur
plein d'autres mesure où on a dit
notamment et on l'a répété tardivement
ce vaccin c'est fait pour vous protéger
alors que non c'est non puisqu'on peut
continuer à le transmettre ce vaccin une
fois que vous l'aurez vous ne pourrez
plus avoir le virus vous ne pourrez plus
le transmettre non c'est faux on ne
savait déjà qu on allait quand même
l'avoir est quand même le transmettre et
ont continué de nous le répéter tout ça
à mon avis par incompétence par
ignorance mais c'est aussi ça donne ça a
fait des dégâts oui mais je pense que
c'est plus de l'ignorance que de
l'incompétence c'est à dire que les
vaccins par exemple les vaccins au début
il y avait eu des essais cliniques mais
n'y avait eu que des essais cliniques
ensuite le virus il évolue donc du coup
il est clair que l' usage du vaccin
évolue donc aujourd'hui en effet on sait
qu il n'empêche pas d'être améliorée ce
qui n'empêche pas de transmettre le
virus mais on sait que dans l'immense
majorité des cas ils empêchent d'aller à
l'hôpital n'empêche les cas graves ce
qui est le plus j'ai dit dans la barre
mais enfin c'est quand même absolument
énorme alors c'est pas du tout je
déteste cette larmoyant à la télévision
veut mais néanmoins vous avez
aujourd'hui des gens dont on repousse
les chimiothérapies vous avez des
services de cardiologie qui sont fermées
donc tout ça n'est pas théorique quand
même il faut c'est là aussi où je parle
d' éthique de responsabilité c'est pas
mal d'aller dans les hôpitaux de voir ce
qui se passe en ce moment en voyez donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle je j'ai
milité pour que la plus grande partie
possible de la population soit vaccinée
je pense que tous ceux qui ont milité
pour sa était dans le vrai et donc ça je
sais vraiment quelque chose auquel
jacques auquel je tiens beaucoup de
choses dans ce que vous dans ce que vous
avez dit mais sur la question de la
morale par exemple enfin je pense pas
que ça s'adressait à moi parce que je
déteste de la morale et c'est pas une
question de morale c'est juste une
question d'efficacité de santé publique
c'est à dire quel est l'outil le plus
efficace pour qu on puisse vivre le plus
normalement et le plus librement
possible c'est la question à laquelle
j'apporte des réponses peut discuter de
la réponse alors moi je déteste la
morale et se détestent et vous ne m'avez
jamais entendu dire j'ai fait beaucoup
d'interventions depuis le début de la
crise on me reproche suffisamment de
trop à l'été mais de 3 à l'été mais vous
ne trouverez jamais une intervention
dans laquelle j'ai pu dire que telle ou
telle personne avait un comportement qui
n'était pas admissible c'est uniquement
sur la question de sur la question de
l'efficacité
après
je me perds parce que comme on a
beaucoup de beaucoup de débats et cour
des comptes dit beaucoup de choses j'ai
perdu j'ai perdu le fil de ma pensée
mais voilà je pense que cette question
du vaccin elle est très importante pour
qu'on puisse maintenir notre système
hospitalier en l'état et dans les pays
dont vous parlez c'est très difficile
analysez vous parler par exemple des
pays scandinaves ou dit en suède il n'y
a pas eu les mêmes mesures mais la suède
est un pays avec une densité qui n'est
pas celle de la france avec des
métropoles qui sont sur la sellette
alors je suis pas épidémiologistes et je
mets deux voilà non mais on peut rendre
parler entre gens qui raisonnent en tout
cas de ce que j'en comprends la
situation quand même et pas la même donc
c'est très difficile de faire ce type de
faire ce type de comparaison voilà moi
je persiste à penser que ce type de
politique c'est la politique qui nous
permet de rester le plus libre possible
vous savez je termine juste mais ces
passages à liberté j'avais bref un bon
là on peut toujours avoir ce débat on
l'a déjà dit mais on n'est pas d'accord
c'est ici bah oui c'est vrai je suis à
la carte et c'est pas à part dont la
liberté ce n'est pas avoir un qr code
pour mes adversaires n'étaient pas
concernés ces soirées
mais mon steak au non plus fait non plus
confinement ou qr code les deux ce n'est
pas la libérer est compatible avec une
pandémie mais non
la question mais en revanche la réponse
est non bah non madoff serait bien alors
dans ces cas là on met en place très
fait la chine comme donc certes allah
vous êtes un défenseur de certainement
par à vous venez dire que
la chaîne va venir mais l inverse c'est
pas là vous venez d'excellents c'est
venez me dire non la chine aujourd'hui
c'est une politique justement qui n'est
pas une politique basée sur le pass
vaccinale et vaccins ne marche pas en
chine il n'y a pas de machine c'est
d'ailleurs ça devrait nous effrayer
d'ailleurs qu'il n'est pas de pas son
choix côté si vous d'avoir
j'avais prédit saissac chinois moi je
leur dit toujours non c'est une
invention occidentale c'est quelque
chose qui vient de chez nous qui vient
de monde capitaliste libérale et c'est
d'ailleurs le l'idée que c'est nous qui
avons créé cette monstruosité devrait
aller du passage
alors salle de bobino et chinois j'adore
aller au bout de votre pensée donc entre
le système de crédit social chinois et
le post vaccinale à la française ou à
l'européenne vous nous dites que vous
préférez le système de crédit social
chinois ah non pas du tout c'est ce que
j'écoute en europe j'ai cru vous
entendre nous avions un sujet gêne
quelque chose de pas venir que le crazy
sound chinois non je dis une chose c'est
intéressant parce que du coup ça ça
vraiment au coeur de notre réflexion sur
la liberté je dis une chose qui est tout
simple c'est que le pass est une
invention occidentale oui on est là que
ce n'est sané ce n'est pas comparable au
crédit social chinois que le pass est
une multi disciplinaire non mais non
c'est purement tomber et ben moi j'ai
juste d'annoncer quoi que je pense que
c'est très intéressant de comprendre
d'où vient le pass afin qu'elle est là
la philosophie d'une basse en fait tu
penses que michel foucault aurait écrit
mais un livre de dix mille pages sur le
dos face à celle de l'euro devant sa
surface et vous avez raison vous dis une
chose très intéressante il nous dit
qu'en gros les sociétés libérales à
partir du xviiie siècle finalement ou
inventer toutes intactes technique
disciplinaire pour alors que les prisons
modernes les cliniques les hôpitaux
tiquer les hôpitaux psychiatriques mais
aussi en termes de biopolitique
l'hygiénisme quoi que ce soit bref et en
fait il faut une chose très simple c'est
que les sociétés libérales n'ont jamais
été libérale au fait germer été libéré
et qu'en fait le libéralisme tel qui
s'est développée dans les sociétés
occidentales a toujours été en fait une
organisation de la liberté et qu'en fait
les pouvoirs ont toujours accordé la
liberté repris les libertés organisé les
libertés mais certaine manière et c est
en fait moi je crois que le pass c'est
un peu l'aboutissement alors
technologique
voilà numérique de sacré logique
disciplinaire et donc moi ça ne m'étonne
pas du tout que ce soit une invention
occidentale
ça doit nous interroger aussi sur notre
notre notre notre enfin voilà notre
modèle politique qui en fait assez peu
libérale qu'on y fasse rapidement là
mais c'est je pense que vous auriez
raison peut-être oui si le pass est
quelque chose qui est prolongé dans le
temps c'est à dire que si dans cinq ans
il ya toujours un pass vous aurez raison
vous aurez raison et vous m'aurez à vos
côtés non mais dis
je mens pas j'ai d'autres défauts mais
mais s'il ya une crise il ya une crise
mais là je suis encore une pandémie si
ça remonte oui mais ça met d'accord ben
alors mais non parce que les pandémies
si la vente n partir de pandémie et si
elle continue pendant deux anciens
nouveaux cas de pandémie
habitué ça fait 2 mais ça fait comment
s'appellent les voyez bien ces cinq sans
limite je vous assure que l'on s'amuse
arrête merci tous les deux de voir
participer merci à ce débat le prochain
c'est lundi mais c'est un peu spécial
l'émission n'aura pas lieu à 19h mai à
20 heures je serai en effet en direct du
théâtre du rond-point
et l'émission sera
alors vous pourrez la voir non pas la
télévision mais uniquement sur les
réseaux sociaux est à voir sur facebook
sur youtube et sur ses poils troisième
ça doit être plus tard huit heures
mais je pense que c'est manon est ce
qu'on peut voir l'émission sur twitter
non je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr faut
pas trop évidente tension c'est sûr
c'est sur internet tout simplement vous
regardez sur rt ce sera le plus simple
voilà et c'est là que vous verrez cette
émission lundi à 20 heures une émission
spéciale donc avec emmanuel todd avec
marcel gauchet beaucoup d'invités
merci
[Musique]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
j'ai su rafler nous pourquoi il s'est
tourné vers le communisme il pensait que
la gauche s'étaient vendus il se disait
la démocratie la démocratie sociale ne
fait pas le travail et il a vu
l'avènement d'hitler en allemagne donc
il regardait l'union soviétique comme un
bastion anti fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la